welcome back to Fatal Frame 2 crimson
burper and where'd it go
photo fancy my stomach sorry I forgot to
sit almost almost almost let's go let's
go I miss my little little friends
frenzies picking up I played a what's
the game call they're all in with more
far and you could pick up stuff and it
was so much more fun when you have
friends and you can pick up stuff like I
don't know you'll see you'll see I know
where to go it's not here it's yeah
maybe that's here no it's not here it's
this way it's kind of tricky part I
didn't think you would actually walk out
of the city to get something but we're
supposedly come on
come on man go faster the frame drops
every time I walk into this place I
don't know why it's kind of obnoxious
but this game is really similar to
Silent Hill like you're walking around
in this dead City and stuff happens I
guess but this is more disturbing in a
way solid table it really didn't make me
but I had a lot of problems in it to
know so we'll see a lot of people
haven't asked me when we finished Silent
Hill and blah blah blah I don't know I
really don't know I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I okay here's the statute
maybe this one no it's not this one okay
thank you but is the thing is they said
they said that it's scattered around the
city and this isn't really the city so
it's kind of a kind of mean of them to
put in here
I hope it's here I don't I don't even
trust anything right now we're back at
the camp yeah there it is
yeah so no we got it now we have the
other King thank you thank you
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it's so creepy taste it
[ __ ]
sorry I shouldn't say that that's a bad
word
let's go court shut okay sweet it's no
problem
oh damn that did enough to any more
damage than I thought
yes
we got them it's your turn smile [ __ ]
ah ah no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no I'm gonna die here now bye it's
my [ __ ] okay and yeah I'm gonna slow
you down yes how does that feel and
you're gonna pose for the camera
[ __ ] it then at the end of damage
it's coming at me it's swinging it
swinging it you're swinging it damn
that's a nice pulse bro where's the
other one
oh crap
that's not where they are nice pose brah
okay wait another one it's like oh [ __ ]
he's coming sex es el ray see other yes
oh you're looking good looking good
that's thick I like that you hello
mister hello sexy yes okay one way ah
come on
I can I just punch him with something
because he's a ghost maybe you're they
later blue ethers hahaha what Christon
lose theirs anymore it's actually there
I know anyway let's go find our sister
she's a [ __ ] a [ __ ] a sister he's
totally it's like I saw what she did
earlier mm-hmm and then speak about
things I think at least I
do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do my finally
some progress oh crap crap not a
cutscene I hate cutscenes
oh that that's really bad
[Music]
hein oh she made it okay let's not bump
into them I don't want to fight anymore
people
Maya stop I think it was a right turn
here yeah I'm pretty sure what do you
think gets you hey don't know I don't
I'm just a have the same voice as I need
to figure out new voices I think but
there's no one to do the voices for
maybe baby in the future who knows
everything can happen
uh go here yes down the stairs and
finally we can progress look at that
slide slide on the stairs so sexy
not even Michael Jackson can do that
move mm-hmm because he's dead anyway
what let's go let's go let's go
I made it I made it I made okay so we
have twin statue thing you're leaving me
my you shine on you give it to me yes I
definitely mean that
No she walks so [ __ ] sometimes come
on let's go Oh anyone there
no he's sick
run wrong anyone there someone having
sex
yeah definitely having sex and yeah okay
that's going here so we're not another
part of the city now oh [ __ ] I don't
like this I don't like this oh there's a
safe station say I don't even have to do
this I can see whenever I want but it's
good just in case because I also love
safe stations thank you
anyway let's go creepy lady where is she
sure you know Oh what is this
where's the shiny object I saw it here
somewhere
and where do the creepy ghost lady go
we came from where oh okay let's go here
then
Oh
[ __ ] ready
oh it's Meyer I think
creepy creepy creepy creepy
perfect perfect you are in trouble
mister miss missus
chapter 3 this is so bad Oh mr. priest
what I can't go back oh man this is
really bad
my you come back to me I see you
terrifying man shine on you cause this
detects the feel of a mother's belly and
sings you to make the light oh sweet
so we see when there's a fatal brain
sweet we came from there it's so
confusing with the camera angle
sometimes ok so it's going here it's
probably a lock but no it's not
are we playing as my you or yeah we are
my I'm a [ __ ] I'm a slip I'm a [ __ ] I'm
a [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
I'm asleep I'm asleep I'm [ __ ] oh I
think we need to watch out for these
[Music]
okay that's a fairly creepy run faster
mm-hmm sure she walks pretty retardedly
I'm just saying let's go here
I don't want to talk to her she's bad
news maybe we can do her something else
because I was talking if you know what I
mean anyway
okay are we walking the same path yeah
we are [ __ ]
come at me bro did nothing
there we go No
ah he's sexy
I missed oh we need to back up we need
to back up smile [ __ ] ha ha what
happening
ha Yahoo I was known sexy hair
I guess it's hired at six years forward
to damage that's what I'm talking about
do it again at [ __ ] there you too
easy three week one more and your date
all right displays how much yeah there's
a fatal frame right there you they later
my babe oh my gosh I'm gonna go oh
what's going on oh no I don't like you I
don't want you why don't you go oh
that's so creepy
Oh bug Oh want to shop Kayla really know
it's just something yes here over here
oh [ __ ]
ah oh this is so creepy this is really
really really really give me oh [ __ ]
she's over here I think here no wait
oh [ __ ] it she's right there oh oh my
god her she likes sure she likes
close-ups the friendly oh man oh I don't
want to go here
oh there's no one I think where did you
she go
I wanna shine I have a flaw right is
this
it must have been beautiful I doubt it
oh no something bad will happen what is
that
[ __ ] are we oh damn
that's messed up
oh no about you she's mean
[Music]
yeah
let's go
[Music]
are you serious no no it's a boss fight
it's a [ __ ] boss fight seriously oh
she's coming at me
oh I killed instantly and I saved right
before I died no oh come on
maybe no I can't no my you I guess away
why do after inside sometimes I have to
go from the last save No
[Music]
come on are you serious
well it says usually if I [ __ ]
replayed you better [ __ ] even watch
it
luckily we can skip these cutscenes
yeah yeah shut the [ __ ] up which way
just let me enter the [ __ ] room why
there's nothing here right shining on
you I get really pissed on stuff like
this happen it's like I make
I'm not even gonna bother with that guy
another cutscene maybe yes
but what I do
you have to run as Meyer and she walks
really stupidly what god I hate her so
much
Jesus that [ __ ] I tell you okay
all right and that was my turn and then
we can go I think I can run past the guy
here in the hallway so it's cool it's
good its color good don't be upset
you can shop you can take a chill pill
you can think you sho poke it's not
gonna be like oh I see you but then I'm
gonna be like oh I'm not gonna oh wait
oh [ __ ]
let me go he's stupid [ __ ]
I can't walk past him really quick there
we go
oh [ __ ] it started - can I walk in here
yeah account good it's just safe stay
here sloth walk remind me that it's all
someone shine on you okay that wasn't
too bad
and then we go here shine on you
can't believe they make you replay
everything after a boss fight yeah we
already seen this it's kind of long just
like my penis
okay okay this yeah that's not what you
were supposed to do
my you